any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
this is my review of professor katie max
the end of
everything astrophysically speaking
this book is a lively antidote to our
otherwise cheerful times
instead of agonizing over a pandemic
political polarization and economic
upheaval
why not fret over the end of the entire
universe
all jokes aside why bother studying our
universe's demise
well as max says contemplating our end
helps us understand the fundamental
nature of reality
itself mack known as astro katie to her
legions of followers on twitter
is a theoretical astrophysicist and
professor of physics at north carolina
state university
she specializes in contemplating cosmic
catastrophes like the big rip
the heat death of the universe and most
terrifyingly
vacuum decay in her skillful hands we
learn that although our cosmic
comeuppance won't be pretty
we at least have billions of years until
it will occur
unless that is if vacuum decay the
transition from the false metastable
vacuum state we may currently be
enjoying
to its true minimum or ground state
causing the instantaneous disintegration
of baryonic matter among other day
ruining effects
which she discusses with the perfect
blend of academic rigor and poetic
license
makes it the ultimate culprit of our
doom in this case
cosmic catastrophe may occur as you hear
the end of this sentence
following yogi bera's dictum that it's
tough to make predictions
especially about the future mack warns
us that the universe's exact fate is
much less certain than how it began
while she largely eschews the typical
approach of recapitulating cosmology's
vast history
she does note that our knowledge of the
origin of the universe too was once
more nebulous well into the 20th century
there were many rival cosmogenies
including cosmic eggs lemaitres primeval
atoms and even the biblical book of
genesis
nevertheless cosmic eschatology has long
gotten short shrift
the end of everything appears exactly a
hundred years after the famous debate
between astronomers harlow shapley
and heber curtis concerning whether or
not the milky way galaxy was itself the
entire universe or
if there were other galaxies in the
cosmos as well the so-called great
debate was resolved three years later
when edwin hubble demonstrated that an
object then known as the great spiral
nebula and andromeda was not a nebula
at all but an entirely separate galaxy
further observations by hubble proved
that the universe was expanding
which immediately prompted speculation
about what happened when its expansion
began
scientists eventually settled on the big
bang theory it rains today
all the while attention to the opposite
end of the timeline if there is one
has been sparse and speculation rains
mac's surprisingly lively account of the
bang's end of time counterpart is
uplifting
with a rye wit permeating its 240 pages
it is meticulously researched nicely
illustrated and copiously footnoted
although footnotes are usually the bane
of the reading experience that is not
so with mac her joke per footnote ratio
is darn near unity comparable
books aimed at popular science audiences
are of course stephen hawking's apocal
a brief history of time and from sabina
hossenfelder's
her book lost in math how beauty leads
physics astray
the latter similarly blends first person
expert perspective
as well as wit as well as interviews
with other experts including some of the
same scientists mac has conversed with
unlike haasenfelder though mac is more
optimistic about possibilities for
scientific progress in realms of
astroparticle physics
that are currently untestable such as
multiverse theories vacuum decay and the
large extra dimensions models
my only minor qualm with this otherwise
masterful book is that it lacks the
vantage point of an experimental
astrophysicist
had mac surveyed a few of us alongside
the many theorists and high-energy
experimentalists she interviewed
it would have added another dimension to
her book instrument builders can and
should act as assayers of the theories
they are testing
amidst max humor is beautiful prose
contemplating future end times research
she writes
someday deep in the unknown wilderness
of the distant future the sun will
expand the earth will die
and the cosmos itself will come to an
end in the meantime we have the entire
universe to explore
pushing our creativity to its limits to
find new ways of knowing our cosmic home
we can learn and create extraordinary
things and we can share them with each
other
and as long as we are thinking creatures
we will never stop asking
what comes next in the end of everything
eschatology meets cosmology evoking at
least in this reader an aphorism from
ecclesiastes
better is the end of a thing than its
beginning
mac's brief history of the future is
bound to inspire minds young and old
not to deny the eventual death of the
universe but rather to embrace it
while there's still time i'm brian
keating chancellors distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california san diego
with this review of kdmax the end of
everything
astrophysically speaking
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
you